genau
[Musik]
guten morgen lukas geht habe ich hoffe
ja ist ja einem wundervollen tag ich bin
gerade erst aufgestanden hat sie ihren
blog schon vor zwei tagen gesehen habt
wisst ihr dass ich gerade noch bei lukas
bin in hannover und gewann 8 bis 4 uhr
ach deswegen haben jetzt erstmal bis 10
uhr geplant ich habe hier auf jeden fall
schon mal gerade den block fertig
geschnitten den ihr von zwei tagen ist
wieder komplett das meisterwerk geworden
weil ich bin ja auch der letzte block s
glaubt wird selig dem versammlungs und
nicht uns ein bäcker auf 10 uhr gestellt
und wollten etwas machen einmal sehr an
aber es ist halt 12 und der kennt immer
noch das heißt wir gehen jetzt einfach
mal rüber das ist ja so normale menschen
dann halt gegen die von unserem alten t
shirt keine ahnung sporthose aus short
lukas er ist einfach in den klamotten
eingeschlafen
klar ist auch nimmt erstmal duschen und
das meistens im block ist dass man das
halt einfach voll schwer machen kann uns
vormachen
einfach schnell und da bin ich mir
duschen das ging tatsächlich sehr
schnell ist übrigens angefangen zu
regnen also ihr wisst schon
das wetter mag nicht lange für das
frühstück noch ganz normal schmeckt
bruderschaft die sich nun könnte
schwachen sie
wir drehen jetzt ein video für lukas
kanal das heißt einfach mal die
beschreibung wenn ihr das video sehen
wollte sollte eigentlich einen link
freundin seien deshalb für mehr als heim
das video fertig aufgenommen
wie gesagt links in der beschreibung
noch ein bisschen freestyle quatsch
machen mäßig ich fahre jetzt schoss
lukas wird dich sehr vermissen aber
hallo porsche
klug ruhig bin wieder zu hause
angekommen
bielefeld eine frage nach wie es ihnen
so bei lukas gefallen hat wie hat sie
bei lukas gefallen dass wir bei dem
waren jetzt gerade in hallo das ist mir
auch aufgefallen ich glaube jetzt eben
den druck hoch den ich heute morgen
schon geschnitten habe deswegen 3 ich
bin jetzt gerade in bielefeld beim
tierpark olderdissen angekommen und wir
gucken uns das thema tiere an
hey was geht
danke danke das ist glaube ich seine
vier geschwister es gibt hier so ab oder
seid ihr die kinder oder was okay
ja das habe ich jetzt verstehen jan ein
alter ego kleider die wollen nicht
gestreikt werden räume genauso seinen
kaninchen aus das ich früher hatte das
ist einfach so ein löwenkopf zwecke
nicht in die suppe
ja unsere sünden gestorben das hier ist
coty beauty komm hol den stock hier
vorne sind wir dann irgendwann sie
angekommen okay was heißt sehe das in
seinem tempel und hier sollen dann geht
nicht bieber sein also wir schauen mal
ein paar schilder bieber ich könnt ihr
euch noch an das wetter nur verändern da
war einfach komplett regen auf der
autobahn und hier in bielefeld
blauer himmel und seitdem ich halt
wieder da bin die mutter läuft ganz
frech weiter und er wird noch weiter
trinken
jetzt fragt sich gerade jetzt da die da
hinten die dieser hier steht er einfach
so majestätisch alter schaut ihn euch an
kann diese tiere fressen sich jetzt das
teil bleibt von dem hirsch das war die
beste aller zeiten mit drogen kaufen
hallo wollen
das geht bei dir so ok chef des nach
vorne und ist kein bart codes der hat
wenigstens im bad immer freundlich sogar
eine tafel für blinde also laser luca
auf instagram folgen brown als alles was
das licht berührt die spätere
gegengewichte keine kinder auf das
gelände selbst darstellen
ich könnte dort erinnern dass ich vorhin
gesagt habe blauer himmel und ich weiß
nicht ob das auch kamera so rüberkommt
aber hier geht gerade wirklich
unglaublich die welt unter das ist nicht
mehr schön mal schauen was da dran steht
überall gesteht caro plus denn noch ein
paar andere sachen hier das haben wir
hier auf insta doppelpunkt laser locker
jetzt ist der himmel einfach wieder blau
herr bielefeld was geht ab aber da unten
ist einfach der luchs luxusflug genau
diese wiedersehen einfach so aus als
würden die gerade auf einer motto-party
der 80er gehen mit diesem schlaghosen
wir sind jetzt wieder zurück auf den
tierpark ich habe die freundin gerade
noch weg gebracht die zu hause und
freiheit selber davos vendetta grillen
wird beispielsweise als beispiel haben
jetzt auch gegessen an der stelle noch
mein papa falls das sie sehen solltest
ich weiß du guckst ab und zu mal videos
auf jeden fall meine sachen hier und
dann sehen wir uns jetzt im auto wieder
wenn ich nach köln fahren nach einer
anstrengenden autofahrt mit viel
aquaplaning auf der a2 und a13 wenn ich
jetzt endlich in köln angekommen und
habe jetzt gerade den film ausgepackt
den ich bin mit dem casting hannover
gekauft haben ist man jetzt wirklich
sehr sehr klein da ist einfach kleiner
als meine hand erledigt so die
beschreibung so ein bisschen durch das
steht dir dieses produkt haben von
kindern ab acht jahren verwendet werden
cool
danke jetzt kann ich den müll schmeißen
man heute ist aber auch wieder viel
passiert freunde ich bin bei lukas in
hannover aufgebracht wenn uns meine
eltern nach hause gefahren denn dann
wieder nach wieder hereingefahren in den
tierpark bin dann heute nacht auf
gestern nach köln an und dementsprechend
bin ich jetzt noch relativ kaputt
deswegen will ich nach den schönen guten
morgen freunde es ist gerade 19 ich habe
um noch inhaltlich einen arzttermin aber
freunde kennen was die möglichkeit bei
mir meine nicht so groß geschrieben da
ich keine zeit zum frühstücken
sport1 nicht wirklich etwas gegessen zu
haben
zum arzt und der wird dann vielleicht
beim abtasten und sohn dann wird der
erst mal hart weil ich so viel hunger
habe ich will wieder zurück vom arzt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die sind nämlich eigentlich immer damen
und herren auf jeden fall lag in meinem
postkasten gerade einen brief von iliad
von manager oder darunter ein
zeitungsartikel an kreischend ausflippen
den berühmtesten youtube an deutschlands
kann man gerade bei dem video das in
köln ganz nah sein du bist nicht dabei
bleiben
bester blocker ich bestimme jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal was zu essen oder
liefert einfach erst ab 11 uhr 30 oder
keine ahnung und nicht bestimmbar ist
mir jetzt also nichts bestellen kann
mache ich mir das einfach selber ich
mich jetzt hier überraschend besitzen
könnten einmal wieder neue episode
machen von luca kommentiert kommentare
wenn ich im nächsten video bin bezahle
ich den rest deines lebens pizza.de ein
wollen darauf verlasse ich mich jetzt
danke dir halo kann macht doch einfach
eine leine und die mit ihm gassi wäre
dann auch wie eine challenge dass ich
glaube blockierte damit auf über den
boden gezogen zu werden und die anderen
leute würden noch alle denken wir sind
von idioten oder denken eh schon
scheißegal noch nicht so viele deiner
fans auto begeistert sind ich
interessiere mich sehr für autos also
wäre es cool wenn du deinen arsch ein
bisschen mehr beschreibt weil sie den
letzten block gesehen haben sollte ist
ihr dass ich von porsche ein neues auto
zur verfügung gestellt bekommen habe den
innenblock gerät ist freitag und morgen
am samstag bin ich am nürburgring dh im
nächsten block den jeder quasi jetzt am
sonntag sehen werdet da wird mehr mit
dem auto kommen also da kannst du dich
dann schon mal darauf freuen
der block war geil doch dann kam niklas
rieger ich verstehe nicht warum so viele
dass gegen lukas liegen also ich habe
auch gesehen dass es so hält seiten gibt
sie irgendwie so fünfstellige abonnenten
haben wo er einfach nur gerettet wird
dann kann man das erklären weil ich
finde eigentlich ganzen der traurig dass
man sich wegen den häschern was anderes
anziehen muss man keinen bock auf haye
hat sehr kommentar bezog sich glaube ich
auf die stelle im letzten block wo ich
gesagt habe dass ich jetzt mal endlich
ausziehen weil ich keinen bock habe dass
leute in die kommentare schreiben dass
das board ist eigentlich komplett
scheißegal
die noch gar nicht mal so viel und den
hält sondern mir geht es einfach darum
dass kooperation oder mehr alle sachen
die ich mache das die halt dass ihr
wisst dass ich gerade werbung machte
also das ist ja fast transparent mache
und ich hatte eine dementsprechend in
dem letzten block kein bock darauf dass
leute die kommentare schleichwerbung für
spiderman obwohl das scheint einfach im
schein oben lag weil ich sie mir eine
sechste andere sachen an oder mit
anderen leuten nicht helfen ich habe
auch ab und zu supreme sachen dann kamen
auch schon leute an meint ö mit kate ist
doch gar nicht jeder sei das einstige
power verbockt alter ich verstehe nicht
wieso das denn sparten eingeteilt wird
wer was tragen da wie heißt das lied
welches du gespielt hast
[Musik]
aber das wird sich auf die stimme habe
also ein richtig schönes piano stehe und
da ist der sound so richtig nein das
kann man so aufklappen und hier sondern
auf dem digital denke dass ich das
richtig zu gut an ich gehe jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal trainieren mit max
immer warte ich auf dich training
beendet jetzt gehe ich erstmal duschen
ich war seit zwei wochen nicht
definieren wird magst du denn heute
wieder im sinne zu verstehen also ich
könnte es nicht glauben
jeder seite im leben ist das wichtigste
das man einfach dran bleibt also sei es
jetzt eben die klavier spielen oder
fitnessstudio oder so man ich für mich
keine motivation dafür auf jeden fall
machen was und ich den fehler dass wir
halt nicht durchgängig wirklich jede
woche vier mal ins schwimmen gehen
sondern eher so ungebrochen nicht damit
oder woche sechsmal jetzt komplett egal
ich habe ein paar socken ich hab ein
paar sachen fisch mit kartoffeln und
sondermüll soße dann dazu sollen laut
spiegel und hier arbeite ich gerade am
neuen mixtape immerhin immer so einfach
mal deine mixtapes auf youtube hoch und
zeigt mal wie du wirklich mixed und soja
bald auf youtube brauche ich ja die
ganzen rechte und auch sonst bräuchte
nicht deswegen ist es auf youtube
bisschen komplizierter bücher gerade so
gemütlich meisten aufgegessen auf einmal
bekomme ich die nachricht doch meinen
laptop essen mit holly menschen 28
minuten das auf jeden fall mega cool
wenn uns so richtig gesättigt ist
sondern auf einmal kriegt man die
mitteilung von seinem macbook in einer
halben stunde ist ein abendessen termin
mit hollywood also band ob steffi als
mina ahadi und alle andern mit denen ich
gleich noch was essen werde ich mich
deswegen hatte ich dann nicht so eine
große hunger als dass er gerade sieht
der vespa holding alles besprochen also
das sind noch mal dass mir durchgegangen
was im ersten zwölf natürlich launischen
werte geht auf jeden fall holen trank
ich sag das nicht nur spaß sondern
wirklich es kommen wieder sachen die
haben wir so einfach noch nicht gemacht
von pa freuen ich habe tatsächlich noch
etwas gegessen und mir ist schlecht
gerade was man auf jeden fall auch
gerade aufgefallen ist ist dass ich
heute noch auf einem geburtstag
eingeladen bin von nem freund formieren
und das habe ich einfach bisher total
vergessen und die ganzen anderen
kollegen von mir sind schon seit drei
stunden da man jetzt sogar wo bleibt
eigentlich nicht so benannt so einer
stunde da ja vier stunden zu spät aber
mal machen mussten
gebt euch mal diese schuhe halter was
hab ich denn da hat gemacht so viele
gefragt was von rucksack ist dass einer
von rincon ist eine kölner war
optimistisch sind die meisten menschen
in sachen ist auf jeden fall entspannt
dass ich wenig deutsche sorgen und die
liebe machen aber ich mache mir sorgen
dass dieser block nicht richtig kennen
während vermag ich ja sonst mal das ende
so ja ich stelle die kamera politik ist
da halt von wegen ich weiß euch raus und
der glocke zu ende und ich mache die tür
zur aber da ich diesmal bei einem
kollegen kennen werde die ampel ist
gerade rot teilen sich eigentlich schon
versprechen heute wird es nicht dieses
typische luca flock ende geben dass ich
euch vor die tür stellen waterpark an
alle kölner er seit wann steht denn das
ding hier hinten
ich bin hier eine zeitlang in zwei tage
früher auf einmal steht ob sie hat auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen das ist im
block an dieser stelle jetzt schon mal
beenden werde weil ich möchte noch nicht
film auf dem geburtstag von freundlichen
das wird auch die ganzen gäste das
wollen deswegen hey lasst like da wenn
sie noch kein abonnent zeit könnte
einfach unter dem video auf abonnieren
klicken und wenn ich schon ab und
entscheide dann könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken
denn dann bekommt die benachrichtigung
sobald ich etwas hoch und dann hören die
nächste episode luca kommentiert
kommentare kommen wollten schreibt wegen
der fragen die kommentare oder irgend
einen dummen kommentar einfach und sonst
würde ich jetzt sagen sehen wir uns
einfach in zwei tagen in dem neuen blog
wieder von daher
[Musik]